[Música]
sempre vivemos em rede ma é uma chamada
que nunca a rede representa o
metáfora do espírito da época para ir
redes uma sociedade em rede a foi o
hiperconectividade são alguns termos que
usamos para nos referirmos a esta revolução
tecnologia que gosta de toda revolução
mudanças históricas profundas na forma como
como nos relacionamos e pensamos
uma metáfora de rede de lendas dá analogia
na rede existem disciplinas que estudam
isso por muitos anos 272 e saudável para
para torná-los mais exatos, temos o
registra as primeiras análises formais
da rede
cientistas como matemáticos sociólogos
antropólogos biólogos cientistas
informática são alguns representantes
que estudam redes com o objetivo
em comum para entender os padrões que
sair dessa relação
Eu que uma rede uma rede é constituída
por dois nós ou entidades visualmente
pontos e pelo menos um link ou link
visualmente uma linha pode ser imaginada
enorme quantidade de redes que podemos
criar, por exemplo, redes de pessoas de
organizações redes de conceitos redes
de coisas ou redes de diferentes tipos mais
ou mais interessantes são os links para
que analisa redes porque através
ele cria padrões de relacionamento
ou links também podem ser variados
laços de parentesco de amigos
links de seguidores e seguiu o
saudades sociais e até laços de
conexões dendríticas
redes aqui vozes de uma rede que formam
as primeiras representações visuais
da internet desse organismo vivo em
constante expansão que tem teia e
obviamente, uma parte disso foi um grande
Avanço para denominar a ciência da
redes que começaram a identificar
alguns padrões, por exemplo, não são
note que esta rede não parece ter um
único centro, muitos acreditavam que o
redes orgânicas têm um único centro
além disso, também não parece distribuído muitos
eles acreditavam que as redes eram
distribuído por em ter um padrão que
é respeitado em diferentes tipos de redes e
é que são redes descentralizadas em
diferentes centros diferentes grupos
diferentes comunidades de influência
outros tipos de redes também serão suficientes
por exemplo biologia recentemente
eles começarão a estudar como são as redes
subterrâneo entre as matas nativas
mas observe como através das raízes
árvores profundas de diferentes espécies
estão conectados entre si criando um
internet dá floresta e ainda tem
fungos específicos localizados
pelas raízes criando conexões
que flui através dessas conexões
nutrientes subterrâneos
até mesmo algumas árvores que são
que sofrem de denso são auxiliados por
outras árvores porque tudo se beneficia ou
definir mais também informações como
as árvores são capazes de receber
informações de outras pessoas através de seus
raízes quando há uma praga é muito
interessante ver também
laboratórios que as plantações
plantações para cujas colheitas eles não
apresentar esses padrões como se fossem
nós e soldados sem conexões que é
funcionários não podem se comunicar e em
Parte disso explicaria o que eles são
muitos sensíveis a pragas
redes é apaixonado por redes e
especialmente redes humanas e como
antropóloga, entendo que as redes
contar uma história que conecta
passado presente e futuro de
humanidade e começou a estudar redes
15 anos atrás, quando eu estava estudando
antropologia mais eram
redes offline, por exemplo, uma iniciada
os anos de 2012 são menos bem compreendidos ou
que não é daqui da Argentina vai surgir
os palácios
e através desses grupos especialmente de
mulheres desempregadas as favelas e os
movimentos de periferia serão criados
luta social muito interessante
mas os recursos escassos do espaço
criando redes confiáveis ​​redes locais
Eram estratégias de sobrevivência
como árvores as florestas nativas
entre 2000 e 2005 me dediquei a
pesquisa redes de microcrédito
microcréditos são um tipo específico de
que o pequeno crédito seja muito notado
mais de 6 dólares por mês para
pessoas que não têm acesso ao crédito
formal que notem uma garantia real de que o
os bancos pedem para evitar ou arriscar lá
ninguém implante sabe o que eu sou
falar agora é muito interessante
observe, por exemplo, os salários do méxico
em chiapas ele ainda tem que estudar isso
fenômeno como as mulheres se organizaram
em pequenos grupos e entre eles levantaram
uma garantia social e fogão faz parte
uma metodologia chamada
os pobres que foram institucionalizados
cabelo mohammad yunus um prêmio nobel o
paz em bangladesh e institucionalizado
este sistema as mulheres porque entre outros
as coisas são bons pagadores e isso é
garantia social que não é mais o que
redes comunitárias pré-existentes
meio dos on's e from's e de ninguém
influência deste crédito social são
muito menor do que qualquer banco embora
Curiosamente, os que mais implantam e nada
são os que têm mais de 20
eles são todos rede é verdade e interessante
é que em algum momento
algo muito bom medida por causa de passar de
estudar redes offline passar para estudar
redes online eu tenho que mudar para ver como
Brasil
logo no dia 21 e isso tem a ver com o
comunidades de conceito de comunidade
há outras razões que nos acompanham
desde o início não somos em essência
caçadores-coletores ainda não nos ouvem
é o fluxo de 30 mil anos atrás é um
projeto feio para viver em pequeno
comunidades e essas comunidades eram de
caçadores-coletores, embora não estivéssemos
nômades como rodrigo favorecem de vez em quando
tanto nós conhecemos outro grupo
embora toquemos bains e meses de informação
um mundo drasticamente sucessivo
revoluções tecnológicas feitas
hoje somos sedentários ou desconhecidos
as consequências do que acumulamos
bains que se reproduzem fazemos uma divisão de
trabalho de classe muito grande e também
que obtemos interesse com enorme
número de pessoas aqui tivemos um
comunidade de caçadores-coletores
atípico porque eu não conseguiria
o rosto de cada um é agora
que permanece intacta essas necessidades
fazer parte das comunidades e hoje é
uma revolução a era da informação e
da internet não é que nos temos
içar-nos corporalmente e içar-nos incorpóreos
conseguimos pertencer a diferentes
comunidades interdigitais para estar com
avatares diferentes que não necessariamente
ao peso real do outro lado
É muito interessante a partir daí
falaba para transição para redes de estudos
digital porque elementos de rede
e comunidades são mantidas e aconteceu que
quando estudei microcréditos
dentro da academia no méxico
Eu conhecia meu parceiro de vida e quem
você em uma história semelhante embora
iniciar o seu parceiro ou parceiro e
daí eu vim para curtir e melhorar ou
Brasil e lá encontrei um fenômeno atrás
Muito particular
orkut mais bela era brasileira deve
soletrar o que estou falando
você tem que entender essa habilidade
cultura que se estende adota dois
tecnologia da informação com um grupo
de colegas que ouvem você trabalhar comigo
Sou muito grato por termos criado
uma plataforma chamada net living algo
assim como estes
vivona dirigem essa plataforma que eles estão para
nuvem é inteligência de rede e
torna possível que diferentes fatos não
grafistas digitais e etnógrafos como o
gosto de falhar o mundo todos ficam
coletar grandes dados públicos na web e
transformar isso em redes redes humanas
coisas que aprendi
redes de mapeamento, por exemplo, polarização
vozes percebem que um mundo é
polarize dow mais e mais nasceu assim
idéias e percepções há dois são um
imagem clássica de democratas e
republicanos são blogs um pouco antigos
2004 representa ainda mais essa polarização em
poucas pessoas blogs sem criação de mídia
se alguma coisa polarizar de uma forma que
não com cérebro de caçador-coletor
temos que evitar sobrecarregar
informação é que escolhemos lados que
queria correr um risco muito alto
simplificar essa diversidade em sempre é
legal e não é ativado um mecanismo
chamado 10 cognitivo por meio do qual
buscamos informações que reforcem
nossas crenças e valores anteriores e
que materializa essa polarização
mais uma coisa não é que procuramos aqueles
informações em que acreditamos
eles são parecidos com você não vê mais eles não sabem
existem muitas máquinas criando notícias falsas e
fingindo ser pessoas e pesos
acredito que ele fez você se conectar em um
grande risco de polarização também
observamos outro fenômeno outro padrão de
redes digitais para hiperconectividade
desde 2011 temos um projeto
chamado twitter diplomas e diplomacia não
twitter ou twitter uma milha muito
usado por políticos nem todo o mundo e
O que observamos é que essa rede tem
densas muito tomadas são devidos em 2011 foram
poucos chefes de estado no mundo
usando o twitter seguindo
comentário em 2017 é aquela bola toda
hiperconectado
o interessante é que está ruim nisso
existe etiqueta de diplomacia digital
ele fez mantilla de fato comeu isso em
2017 começou a twittar donald trump e
lá todo o torno foi montado complexo
velocidade de conclusão da difusão
percepções de ideias e dois outros
padrões que observamos em diferentes
redes, por exemplo, relacionadas a tópicos
críticos como os transgênicos ou
organismos geneticamente modificados ou
o brasil tem um recurso
particular que ele é impactado mais do que o
tendências campanhas de percepções
torrado eua que dá europa e o que
observamos nossas redes que além de
acima estão os influenciadores
físicas e jurídicas que incidem sobre
organismos geneticamente modificados para
a favor ou contra o que acontece é quando
a costa oeste leste dois estados
uniram uma campanha contra
indústria cada vez mais biotecnológica
rapidamente se torna viral indo de blog para
blog influencers influencer up
chegar ou brasil ainda não brasil para
decisões políticas do governo
definir uma parte pouco afetada
fisicamente uma sociedade civil
organizado
quanto mais acreditamos que ele está se movendo
estrondo
não somos de polarização fomos de
álamos adif de hiperconectividade
também de viralização mais também
surgir muita situação positiva tem que
veja um pouco com as palestras que
vem acontecendo hoje em alguns
comunidades digitais que nos chamamos
de comunidades de prática que
fazer com as causas e aquelas que estão surgindo
eles estão articulando um dos tem que ver
com a igualdade de gênero e já o segundo
ano consecutivo monitoramos isso
fenômeno ou dia internacional da mulher
8 de março foi há pouco tempo
veja como temos uma rede muito mais
articulados em 2017 foram diferentes
pequenas comunidades cada uma de seis
agrupamentos desses agrupamentos
representou um grupo específico por
exemplo de cultura política
movimentos feministas de educação não sabem
estavam sentindo muita falta um do outro em 2018 e
estão se movendo para redes muito mais densas
que haja mais diálogo entre
diversa porque obviamente requer uma
consciência e todos nós sabemos o
tristes acontecimentos recentes e
temos que refletir como colaborar para
que esta rede tenha cada vez mais força e
impactar a opinião pública e
decisões
salgueiro para segunda organização mundial de
saúde mais de 70 por cento dos
mortes no mundo tem a ver com
quatro defesas câncer diabetes
doenças respiratórias e
cardiovascular uma verdadeira luta
contra esta rede que cresce cada vez mais
a rede de cruza o centro da veia interna para
própria organização mundial de saúde
que se amplia responsável por levantar
conscientização e políticas públicas e
por sua vez eu tenho vários
organizações de peso muito atrás
relacionado com as Nações Unidas
apoiar essas ações.
comunicação mais uma rede de muitos
técnica é muito fria muito corporativa
podemos ter um intruso ou jamie oliver
que um influenciador mais celebridades mais
que o adotou por causa da obesidade
crianças de uma forma autêntica e há autocarros
venha colocar o alvo dos segmentos
apoiou o número três de bem-estar e
saúde e ele é como um intruso mesmo
tem percebido p organizações
paralelos importantes como concedido é
saber adotar saber trapacear
influenciadores muitos leds digitais
poder passar para muitas mensagens
as pessoas não sabem que ter mais defesa
não transmissível o ás em diabetes
e aqui estou eu em um julgamento
falando de diferentes comunidades que
eles estão realmente movendo a indústria
beleza e moda e cosméticos e
O que isso tem a ver com quem eles são?
influenciadores não para o brasil mais temos
visto no mundo já tinha vários saudáveis
Esta é a plataforma colaborativa que
Eu mencionei isso em diferentes comunidades
como por exemplo revolução fácil com
alguns influenciadores lá
tem a comunidade de empoderamento
feminino na comunidade e
espiritualidade da sustentabilidade finalmente
algumas comunidades visitadas que
fazendo um movimento estamos articulando
online e offline e ou nós vale um
é pouco para entender esse fenômeno
ajudar essas comunidades a
conectar e impactar os diferentes
indústrias neste projeto que
Vamos passar algum tempo e deixá-los ser
o suficiente para fazer com o que era o salgado
e está falhando hoje
finalmente eu queria deixar um
provocação que às suas comunidades de
Vázquez essa pergunta tem a ver com o que
que nós falsos humanos e também temos que
fazer com explorar e extrair ou melhor o
tecnologias de informação que não
eles sabem tão bem como usar o porquê
ou perigo é evitar a polarização
simplificação de ideias
diversidade é tão absolvição e um
mundo sempre foi complexo ou manso já
é particularmente na rede muito quente
[Aplausos]